foreign
motionless halfway up the stairs who do
you think you are robbing the Frog
you'll get more beautiful every time I
see you backhanded compliments that
refer to previous backhanded compliments
hello may I present Miss Lana King
purposely naming a character Lord
felchley that name really sucks guys I'm
not sure I get this one
what do you mean you won't explain it to
me I think maybe you mean my ex all
right sure how does monocle man not
remember Archer when he's clearly been
hitting on Archer's mom whose name is
also Archer for all of the sometimes
memories
a secret agent finishing other people's
sentences Ian get out of my closet I
know you're trying to borrow my polka
dotted smoking jacket without asking
again and I don't like it come on don't
be like that hiding your bomb vest under
an easily torn away dress that's just
poor tailoring thinking a standard
champagne serving dish has the tensile
strength to penetrate the human skull
hey come on you know I never let
anything happen to your bacon that's
because you're a good friend Archer
unlike some polka dotted smoking jacket
thieves I know who would eat all your
bacon and until you none was ever made
even though I'm a man with the nose over
here cannonballing into your mother's
beverage the proper entry technique for
maternal cocktail diving Aesthetics is
the jackknife everyone knows that well I
think she was just shaken up
Cyril the writing on this show is clever
enough to make a sound reverse James
Bond joke here and confident enough not
to rub our doctor noses in it I'm
getting very distracted by these
containers specifically the one that
says poison it's in the singular and not
the plural so does that mean it's just
one poison in a plastic container is
that even efficient how do you pour it
into a small or something without
spilling it all over the sides will it
have the same effect the acid had on
Jesse's bathtub in that episode of
Breaking Bad are my confusing acids with
poisons am I even here am I even real
also these bins behind Krieger appear to
be the same bins we see behind Archer
I'm not saying it's impossible to have
multiple duplicate bends I'm just saying
it's wildly inefficient also also this
container over here just says Exit does
it have exit signs in it is there portal
that takes you to Narnia no seriously is
it a portal that takes you to Narnia
hello herpes title of the new reality
game show I'm pitching to the major
Network somehow makes it into the
episode so ditch this hey that's unless
you can throw around corners Cheryl was
long gone by the time you threw that pin
and if she ducked back around the corner
just to get hit by that pin well that's
on her I'm so over that lame flexicon
when does the HSA start lame flex
account Lane flex account I mean sure
the employer has more control and the
amount doesn't roll over but there are
so many extra qualifications within HSA
that most people just can't Cyril's off
somewhere with Mr Archer calling him Mr
Archer and did you just cut me off did
you know that for hsas you have to have
a high deductible I'm sorry cereals off
what with whom I think somewhere with
the what there and Mr Archer was the
whom Cheryl would be the Carol of TV
sins I forgot about the dd14 screw him
screwing the dd14s like you'd recognize
a vegetable that wasn't wrapped in a
Monte Cristo sandwich first of all you
keep that powdered sugar covered deep
fried ham and cheese dipped in raspberry
jam sandwiches name out of your [__]
mouth in second how does it make it
easier to recognize a vegetable when
it's been wrapped in something else if I
don't know the difference between a
disgusting in a disgusting cucumber
sneaking one into the middle of my
delicious Monte Cristo isn't going to
help the situation think your fat
shaming through Mallory it's the least
you could do elevator door stays open
long enough for Lana to have this combo
with Archer and Cyril even though no one
is pushing a button to hold it open and
you're cooking dinner later yes I am
yeah marriage karate the Dane Cook of
martial arts Dane Cook the Tai Chi of
outdated stand-up references wow Archer
you were right a tailored suit hangs so
much better how would you know you
weren't even wearing the jacket and
you're just now getting your seams
measured this is like the first step in
the process do you even want pants
because this is how you get pants when
would you use an underwear gun I mean I
feel like the correct question should be
when would you not use an underwear gun
but you do you close-minded zero not
wearing a shirt under your overalls
they're not called over nothings decorum
it's the chafing you should really be
concerned about I bet agent Kane thunks
it plenty you bet she does what speaking
loudly enough to be heard in the other
room through the door you left open
while your boss is lying in the same
room on the couch and in how convenient
it was that Lana was just standing there
for no particular reason and with tax
fees and we'll throw in some Centrist
that comes to 21.69 you should be
thankful you have zero well for about 12
Reasons from my understanding she'd be
thankful for about seven or so of those
reasons and have about five reasons to
consult her doctor for bruising smatter
face
Rachel catch something isn't this the
same woman from the opening scene it's
amazing how small the world can be
especially when you're trying to cut
down on the animation budget ready sir
Archer's careless and nonchalant sure
but not usually with his own life so
standing in the line of fire during this
exercise seems too dumb even for him
oh we need to go baby you hit it
considering I heard eight shots and I
only see six bullet holes in the pillow
I need to know where those other two
bullets went and why everyone seemed so
impressed by his 75 accuracy trinette
somehow manages to knock the pin lid off
and get poked by the needle with the
same quick hit and that's an impressive
feat pay her twice her going right
because she's working that plot like a
pro having two half cupboard sections in
your kitchen and not using either one
for a microwave and did you say you'd
cook or did I mishear that I know I
misheard you about Jane because turns
out I ran into her then why are you just
calling Cyril now seems like Lana's
phone's best feature is its dramatic
timing oh God I should never have agreed
to this which part firing live ammo
inside continuing to carry around a
toxic pen in your pocket putting
trinette in the trunk just want to be
clear which thing that your character
would probably never agree to that your
character for some reason agreed to that
you were speaking of no whoa you want
the lowest deductible well then I guess
maybe you should have gone with the flex
account after all huh because I don't
want Sterling to end up with a woman
like Lana Kane
magada black that's right Ops field
agent oh nationist yeah that's Rogue
nationist is what I was always going to
say this is like Oh Henry and Alanis
Morissette had a baby and named it this
exact situation I think it would make
more sense for them to name the baby I
have no clue what irony is but I'm still
gonna keep the millions I made off the
word Henry because a man like you Cheryl
doesn't deserve a woman like Lana
culturally biased relationship
equivalencies we'll find out here
shortly that this is Lana shooting at
Archer and Cyril Lana is putting her own
life and the life of her co-workers at
risk to make a point about deception I
guess honestly how am I supposed to take
any of this show seriously anymore I
hookers in the trunk unconditional love
well you shot him shot a machine gun at
me
around you these three bullet holes
would like to offer a semantic
Counterpoint when we first started going
out I may have injected a tracking
device into your body making Lana the
insecure and more crazy one in this
relationship is kind of interesting but
also 100 unbelievable oh my God brunette
yeah
making me wish I was watching
reservation dogs instead of this right
now you know I bet there's a lesson to
be learned from all this yeah probably
something about how characters early on
in exaggerated comedies feel like
Shadows of over the top and lofted
unlikable stereotypes that when looked
back upon will feel false and
inconsistent to what they might become
probably something like that
thank you
my rocket you're sold my lucky rug
what's up buddy I'm not your buddy
friend what's this well uh see uh here's
the thing yeah kid I'm getting out of
here
Daryl watch yourself Cyril check this
out
really sure it looks like a Smurf penis
smatter baby fridge you'll catch
something
oh my god did you hear that what do you
think it is immigrants we got the job
done oh and uh Archer how do you like
their Maps